Today we're going to start with uh
finitely
repeated games.
And I want to just start with a really
simple example and we'll actually play a
game together and then we'll develop the
general uh theory of this. So let's
recall the standard prisoner's dilemma
game where
each player had two choices. They could
either cooperate with the other player
or they could defect.
And the payoffs that we wrote down are
going to be 2 2
3 -1 -1 3
uh 0 0.
And what we saw in this game is that for
both players defecting is a strictly
dominant strategy. So
if the opponent cooperates, I'm better
off if I defect cuz 3 is better than 2.
And if the opponent defects, I'm still
better off if I defect because 0 is
greater than -1.
But so far we've assumed that this game
is played only once. In reality, a lot
of interactions take place over time.
You play a game with someone, you see
what happens, then you play the game
again. Then you see what happens, then
you play the game again.
And uh today we're going to study what
happens and how our conclusions change
when we're in this kind of repeated
situation.
So let's start with a really simple
let's play the prisoner's dilemma
three times.
So how does this work? You're going to
simultaneously play the game.
Then both players observe the actions
that were taken.
Then the game is played again.
Both players observe the actions that
were taken and then finally the game is
played a third time.
And we'll assume that your payoffs in
this
you know, grand game are just the sum of
your payoffs or the maybe the average
payoffs across the games.
So if you get two in every each
repetition of the game, your average
payoff is two. Um I think it's good it's
fun to just sort of play this. So we
could do it on MobLab, but I feel that
if you kind of look someone in the eye
when you're playing the game, it changes
the results a bit. So I want you to pair
off and uh you need a way to to play
this. I think the easiest way is to
think of this as like rock paper
scissors. So just agree maybe rock if
you need help let's say
playing rock is defecting and maybe
playing paper
is cooperating. So then it's just a
variant of rock paper scissors. Play it,
observe the outcome, you play it again,
observe the outcome, you play it again.
So three times in total. Pair up, maybe
one of you will be by yourself, you can
observe other people.
Um
and yeah. Let's uh let's do it and see
what happens.
All right, so let's see how I'm curious
how people did. So
I hope most groups got a chance to play.
So tell me how how did people play? Um
does anyone want to share what you found
when you played this game?
Yes.
So you guys uh you cooperated in all
three rounds or
Okay, interesting. That's that's pretty
good payoffs for you guys. Uh so you
each got an average payoff of two.
That's pretty good. Uh I would argue
maybe someone was a little irrational
there, but we'll see. Anyone else?
Uh did other people cooperate? Yeah?
Great. That's a that's a great point. So
we'll see actually that the theory of
infinitely repeated games is much
different than the theory of finitely
repeated games and Paul Milgrom loves to
say the game is always larger than you
think. So when you write down these
games, often we're missing additional
interactions that we might not be
modeling. Um okay, so a lot of
cooperation. Did anyone just defect
every time?
Yeah?
Okay. Great. A paragon of rationality
and uh and what was your reasoning? Uh
did you did you have reason or uh
Okay.
Great. So it seems like we have a few
different approaches. Some people sort
of said, well, we understand that in the
stage game defecting is optimal.
So let's just let's just expect that the
other player is going to defect and
we're both going to defect every period.
Other people seem to be able to sustain
some cooperation and maybe what you had
in mind is if we cooperate today, then
tomorrow my opponent will reward me by
cooperating in the future, right? Uh
we'll see that in the finitely repeated
game, the unique subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium is actually uh always
defecting. So as as one of these groups
played and the way these other groups
played is not actually consistent with
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium, but
let's uh let's understand why.
So I think the first key observation
here is that when we play a game
repeatedly
so repetition
I guess I should say together with
observability
creates the opportunity for rewards and
punishments, right?
I think what some of you might have
thought is maybe if I cooperate today,
I'll be rewarded and my opponent will
cooperate with me in the future and I'll
get some benefit from that. Or
conversely, if I defect today, my
opponent might punish me by defecting in
the future.
Notice that we need both repetition and
observability for this to happen, right?
Of course you need repetition because
you need some future for people to
reward or punish and we need
observability because the only way to
reward and punish people is if you make
your future play contingent on what was
done in the past. If you couldn't
observe the way people played, then uh
the repetition wouldn't really be so
important.
Great. So now let's see if we can uh
formally model this this game and solve
for a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
The the three copy version actually gets
a bit messy. So let me just go over the
two copy version and then we'll we'll
generalize from there. So let's imagine
that the game is played twice. So maybe
I'll say this is prisoner's dilemma
times two.
And even with this very simple game and
just two repetitions, the game tree is
going to get pretty complicated, but
let's see if we can write it out. So
we'll say
maybe the first player is choosing
between
cooperate and defect.
And then the second player
without observing what the first player
did, is also going to choose
between cooperate and defect.
Now remember, we've chosen to model it
this way as the first player going
first, but it doesn't really matter. We
could also have the second player going
first and then the first player moving
not having a observed what the second
player did, right? The key thing is that
this is really a simultaneous move game
because neither player's action can
depend on what the other player is
doing.
Okay, so this was kind of the first
period. Often we call this period zero.
Uh we often start our labeling at zero.
And now we have the second period. So
now
player one
chooses
between cooperate and defect.
And notice these are in separate
information sets to indicate the fact
that at this point the players observe
what happened in period zero. You know
whether both players cooperated, both
players defected, one cooperated, the
other defected or vice versa.
And then
these are going to be in the same
information set because this is really a
simultaneous move game.
And this is player two.
And player two chooses cooperate or
defect.
YOU SEE THIS GETS A BIT MESSY.
AND I THINK YOU SEE the pattern.
And then I could write it all the
payoffs, but uh that's going to be a bit
time consuming. So I won't write out the
payoffs.
So we want to understand what are the
SPNE
of this game?
And what's the first question we always
ask when you try to solve for SPNE?
Well, first we have to identify the
subgames, right? That's always step one.
So how many subgames? Maybe I'll write
down here. This is period one.
So which nodes of this tree start a new
subgame?
Well, there's one easy answer. It's this
node. I don't know if I have colored
chalk today. I'll just use arrows. So
this node starts one subgame that's just
the entire game. That's easy.
And what other nodes start subgames?
Well, we know that if a node is going to
start a subgame, it has to be by itself.
If a node is with another node in the
information set, that node can't start a
subgame cuz that goes against the
definition of a subgame.
And it it has to be a decision node. So
it can't be any of the terminal nodes.
It can't be any of the nodes that are in
multi-node information sets. So actually
we immediately see that it's just these
four.
So what we see
is first let's look at the subgames.
And it turns out there's five subgames
and here we we see the general pattern.
There's one subgame starting in period
zero.
And then there's four subgames starting
in period one where each of those
subgames corresponds to the history of
play that the players have observed. And
in period one, there's four possible
histories. Cooperate to cooperate,
cooperate defect, defect cooperate, and
defect defect.
Okay.
So now let's use our usual approach and
let's try to work backwards.
>> So, let's start with our smallest sub
games, the sub games that come at the
end.
And in the sub game starting here,
if we're looking for a sub game perfect
Nash equilibrium, the restriction of the
strategy profile to this sub game must
be a Nash equilibrium of this sub game,
right? So, how are the how must we play
in this sub game to be consistent with
Nash equilibrium?
Defect defect, right? Because we know
maybe I'll
do it here.
That if we fill in this game,
we see that DD is the unique
Nash equilibrium of this stage game,
right?
Now, you might say, "Well, wait a
second. In this sub game, we're not
quite playing the stage game." Because
the payoffs I'm going to put at the end
here don't just depend on what happens
here, they also depend on what happened
in the first game, right? But that's not
going to change incentives because the
payoffs we got from the first game are
sunk. We've already got those payoffs.
So, the only effect that my play has
today is on the the game that we're
playing today, right? The fact that we
add in yesterday's payoffs doesn't
change uh the return to my actions. So,
indeed, we must be defect defect here.
And the same reasoning says we have to
be defect defect here,
and defect defect here, and defect
defect here.
So, what we've seen is that at each of
the stage
maybe I'll say the stage period one or
yeah.
In each of the period one sub games,
we know that defect defect must be
what's played.
And now let's go to the period zero sub
game.
Well, now this is where things are more
complicated because here there's the
possibility of rewards and punishments,
right? But I argue that in this period
zero sub game, we still must both play
defect defect in this in period zero.
Why is that? What would happen if we
weren't playing defect defect?
What's the key
observation here?
Well, I guess the first thing I'd point
out
is
we don't have any rewards or
punishments.
Why? Because we've already computed what
happens in the period one sub game.
And what we've seen is that both players
are going to play defect in period one
regardless of what was done in period
zero.
So, because the future play is
independent of the past play, there's no
scope for rewards and punishments. So,
this is kind of an important point.
Another way of saying this is how I
behave today has no effect on how we're
going to behave tomorrow. Because
whatever we play today, the same
behavior DD is going to be played
tomorrow.
So, how should I play today?
If how I play today has no effect on
what happens tomorrow, I should simply
do today what maximizes my payoff today.
And we know that the unique Nash
equilibrium of of the prisoner's dilemma
is DD, so in the period zero sub game,
we both must play DD.
So, that was kind of a
of a verbal argument, but let's see any
any questions on that?
So, just to make sure
we understand what's going on,
what is the strategy? Maybe I'll put it
over here.
What is the strategy that each player
plays?
So, I might say the outcome of this game
is we just always defect. But remember
there's a difference between the outcome
and the strategy, right? So, what is a
strategy of a player in this game or in
this Nash equilibrium? Well, a strategy
is a complete contingent plan.
And the number of information sets is
actually exactly the same as the
histories here. Because when when am I
called upon to play? Either I know it's
period zero,
or I'm called upon to play in period
one, and I know what happened in period
zero.
So, a strategy needs to specify
we'll write it like this.
SO, WE HAVE
ONE SPOT FOR each possible information
set.
Notice I'm being if we look really
carefully at the game,
then the information sets for player one
are this node,
this node, this node, this node, and
this node.
The information sets for player two look
a little different. It's this dotted
line,
this dotted line, this dotted line, this
dotted line, this dotted line, but we
can really think of them as as being the
same. Because in both cases, the player
either we're in period zero, or we're in
period one, and all we know is what
happened in the first period. So, the
fact that
player two comes later and it's dotted
versus not, it doesn't actually change
things at all.
So, what is this the Nash equilibrium or
the sub game perfect Nash equilibrium we
found? It's it looks like this.
This is a full description of the
strategy. So, it says,
"Initially, before we played it all, I'm
going to play defect.
Then, in the second period or the I was
the first period, the second, you know,
in the in the next game,
if I observe that we both played CC last
game, then I'm going to play defect. If
I observe that we played CD, I'm going
to play defect. If we observe that we
played DC, I'm going to play defect. And
if DD, play defect. So, this specifies a
complete contingent plan in the game."
Notice one kind of subtlety here,
and this will come up. We normally think
that how you play in future games will
be contingent on how your opponent
played in the past, right? This is how
we think about rewards and punishments,
right? If you play C today, I might
behave differently tomorrow.
And that's possible.
But in general, we can actually do even
more. That what a strategy allows us to
do is make our future play contingent
not only on what the other player did,
but actually what we ourselves did,
which may seem a bit weird, but this
will also come up, right? I might say,
"I'll play C tomorrow if I played C in
the first period."
But I'll play something different if I
play D in the first period. That's
allowed. We can contingent make future
play contingent on our own play. Uh and
that that will actually play an
important role below.
Okay. So, now that we've done an
example, let's introduce a general
framework for finitely repeated games.
You can see this was the simplest
possible game. It was prisoner's
dilemma, and we only played it twice,
and already the extensive form got
really messy. So, we're not really going
to draw any more extensive forms, and
we're going to introduce special
notation for repeated games that's a bit
more convenient. So, maybe I'll call
this the the general framework
for finitely repeated games.
All right. So, what's the first
ingredient? Well, the first ingredient
is the game that we repeat, right? So,
this is called the stage game.
So, in our example, the stage game was
the prisoner's dilemma, but it could be
any simultaneous move or any strategic
form game.
And
we're going to call the stage game we're
going to specify it like this.
AND WE MIGHT CALL THIS GAME G,
WHICH is a strategic form game.
So, what does this say? It says in the
stage game,
player one can choose any action from
the set A1, player N can choose any
action from the set AN.
And then we have a payoff function that
says, "What is player I's utility as a
function of the profile of actions
that's played in the stage game?" And we
specify that function for all players I
equals one through N.
Now, we might call the stage game G,
and this is just a strategic form game.
You may notice though that the
notation's a bit different. In the past,
early in the course, when we wrote a
strategic form game down, what was
different about the way we wrote it
down? We used different notation here.
Remember?
These A's are different, right? Before
we wrote S's. We had S1 up to SN.
And we can think of these as basically
the same playing the same roles as the
S's, but we don't want to get confused
between strategies in the stage game and
strategies in the grand repeated game.
So, now I'm going to change notation a
bit, and I'm going to call what we do in
the stage game an action rather than a
strategy, but that's just uh
terminology. So, here, before we said C
and D were strategies in the stage game,
now we're going to say that C and D are
actions in the stage game. So, that we
can keep keep track of what a strategy
is in the full game.
Okay?
Then we have to specify the timing.
And remember this is finitely repeated,
so we're going to say that time goes
we're going to start time at zero, and
that'll be a bit convenient. We'll see a
bit later.
And we're going to have period zero,
period one, period two,
all the way up to period T,
where T
is finite.
So, T is sometimes called the big T is
sometimes called the horizon of the
game.
And notice we actually play the game big
T plus one times because we started
zero.
And for this reason, we sometimes call
the repeated game
maybe I'll call it G of T.
So, the idea is G is our notation for
the stage game.
G of T denotes the repeated game where
we play the stage game G in period zero
all the way up to T.
So, just so we're on the same page, G of
zero
is equal to G. Because if we play the
repeated game, but a horizon is zero, we
just play it once, and that just
coincides with the stage game. But in
general, this game is going to be more
complicated. So what did we play here?
We played G of one.
Our horizon was one cuz we played it in
period zero and period one, and G was
the prisoner's dilemma. So
uh as an example,
just to kind of remind ourselves,
what we played so far could maybe be
called PD of one.
The game is the prisoner's dilemma, and
our horizon was was one.
Okay, we next have to say
uh something about information.
And what we're going to assume is that
past actions are observed.
And this was already assumed in our
example. What we're saying is, whenever
we play the game together, we've
observed exactly how people played in
the past.
So for instance here, when we play the
game for the second time, we observe how
people played it the first time. And we
pointed out that that was crucial, this
observability was crucial to create the
opportunity for rewards and punishments.
And
now we have to say what our payoffs are.
Let's use average payoffs. So maybe I'll
just write UI
Maybe I'll be a little more precise.
So what I'm saying is, let's say I'm
player I,
and this is how we play.
Or this is the outcome of the game. In
period zero, we play the action profile
A0, and all the way into period T, we
play the action profile AT. I want to
write down what is the payoff of player
I.
And this is just going to be the sum.
I'll write it here. It's going to be 1
over T
plus one
of
UI of A0
plus all the way up to UI
of AT.
So I look what happens in stage zero or
period zero, I compute my payoff there.
I go all the way up to period T, I
compute my payoff there.
Altogether, I have T plus one terms, and
it's convenient just divide it by T plus
one. That doesn't have any effect on
incentives. We can always scale
utilities however we want, but it means
that we're kind of computing utilities
in the multi-period game, in the
repeated game, in kind of the same
utility units as the stage game. And it
turns out that that's convenient so that
our payoff will be something like two or
three, rather than seven or eight, which
isn't in the same terms as uh as the
stage game.
All right.
So now let's talk about strategies.
And before we Maybe before we define
strategies,
let me just make one note
that a finitely repeated game,
this is a special case
of a multi-stage game.
Remember in a multi-stage game, we
separated the game into stages, and in
each stage, some subset of players moved
simultaneously having observed what
happened in previous stages.
This is a special case because the
subset of players who move is always all
the players,
and the game they play is always the
stage game.
So in in more generally in a multi-stage
game, the the the stage game could vary
over time. We might play a different
game in period zero as we do in period
one. This is a special case in that we
always play the same stage game in every
period.
So because this is a multi-stage game,
what does that tell us we can apply?
Let's just sort of keep in mind, why
might this be be useful for us? What
What's a general result we know about
multi-stage games?
Remember?
If we want to check that something's a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium in a
multi-stage game,
it's a bit easier to check because of
what result?
The one-shot deviation principle, right?
So the one-shot deviation principle gave
us an easy way to verify that a given
strategy profile was in fact a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
The one-shot deviation principle applies
to any multi-stage game,
and finitely repeated games are special
case of multi-stage games, and therefore
the one-shot deviation principle applies
to these games as well.
And we'll use that fact below.
Okay, so now let's define what a
strategy is.
Let's say for player I.
And as usual, a strategy is a complete
contingent plan.
So we have to say how player I will
behave at every possible contingency
player I finds herself at.
Again, let's separate this into periods.
We have period zero,
period one,
to generic period T, and then eventually
we get to
Well, at period zero, nothing has
happened. So we just have the trivial
history. So at period zero, my strategy
must say SI of the empty set
in AI.
So my strategy SI
is going to say, what action do I take
in period zero? Well, at the null
history. We haven't observed anything,
nothing has happened so far. So we're
going to use the empty set to denote the
history in period zero.
Then in period one,
we need to specify SI of H1.
This is going to be an action in AI.
And we have to specify this
for every history
H1.
This is a period one history.
H1. Well, where do these things live?
Well, a period one history just
specifies what happened in period zero.
And crucially, not just what I did in
period zero, but what my opponents did.
So this is going to be an element of A.
It's going to be an action profile.
Remember A, let me write is A1
to AN.
So what this says is in period one, as
player I, I'm going to choose some
action to play,
and the action I choose can depend upon
the way that we played in period zero.
Namely, the action profile that we all
took in period zero.
Okay, if we extend this and we get to
period T, what happens? We're choosing
SI of HT
in AI.
And again, for every history, but now we
have every history HT
in what? Where does HT live?
Well, in period T, I observe how
everyone behaved in period zero, in
period one, all the way up to period T
minus one.
And altogether, that's actually T
periods. So this is going to be in AT.
You might It might be a little confusing
why it's AT because it only goes up to T
minus one, but remember we started at
zero. So actions profiles in zero, one,
two, all the way up to T minus one,
there's T of those altogether.
And then we could go down to to T.
So maybe if we wanted to say really to
be
really formal here, what is it?
A strategy
SI is a function
that specifies what player I does at
every possible
history.
So maybe we could write this as a
function from the union
from T equals zero to T
of AT
to AI.
So this is I think the the way to
interpret it, but if you want to think
formally mathematically, well, I have to
specify what I do at every history. So
I'm going to take the union of all the
sets of histories. And this will specify
the period zero history, all the period
one histories, all the period two
histories, all the way up to all the
period T histories, and this is going to
be the formal way I I write it down. But
um you know, that's sort of the math
way. This is I think the uh intuitive
way to do it. And you'll notice this is
maybe the way that we'll write it down
in the examples, that'll be a bit
clearer.
All right. Any questions on
the setup, on how we've defined
a finitely repeated game?
Yeah.
Just a question. So for that game of the
prisoner's dilemma, what are the two
actions? Yeah.
And it just so happened that both
players had like identical strategies,
but probably we need to specify two of
those.
Exactly right. So I should have said,
yeah, this is strategy
uh S I. Exactly right. So, the
equilibrium good point. So, the
equilibrium that we solve for has to be
a strategy profile. So, maybe I would
say it's actually S1 equals S2 equals
this.
Yeah. Great. Thanks for clarifying.
That's a symmetric equilibrium. We could
also have potentially asymmetric
equilibrium. Yeah. Great. Any other
questions on this?
All right.
So, now we want to understand
what's kind of special
and what happened here. We wrote down
this model thinking that there would be
maybe a potential for cooperation using
rewards and punishments where people
might play differently early on in the
game anticipating what happens later on
in the game.
But then we we looked at the prisoner's
dilemma
and we found that it didn't happen. We
always just played the Nash equilibrium
of the prisoner's dilemma every period.
So, let's try to understand how general
that phenomenon is. Uh and that'll be
what our first result tells us.
So, one special property of the
prisoner's dilemma
is that the stage game only has one Nash
equilibrium. It had a unique Nash
equilibrium.
And we'll see that when the stage game
only has unique Nash equilibrium, that
puts a lot of structure on the subgame
perfect Nash equilibria of the repeated
game. So, let's uh
state this theorem.
So, let G
be a strategic form game. This is going
to be our stage game.
So, this is an arbitrary strategic form
game, maybe finite, but uh
I don't know if they can define it this
um
if
this game G
has a unique Nash equilibrium.
Then
Okay. So, we've started with an
assumption about our stage game and
we've assumed that our stage game G has
unique Nash equilibrium. We want to draw
a conclusion about the repeated version
of this game.
And we actually want a conclusion to
hold no matter how many finitely many
times we repeat it. So, I'm going to say
then
for every
horizon
T
the game
G of T
So, I'm going to finish my sentence, but
let's just make sure we see what we're
doing. We've We've started with a a
single game G.
We've made an assumption about it that
it has unique Nash equilibrium. And now
we're going to draw a conclusion about
the T repeated version of this game for
every horizon T.
Namely, the game G of T
has unique
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
We can actually say more. Any guesses on
what this
unique subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
might be?
Yeah. It's G's Nash equilibrium.
Exactly. And we have to be a little
precise. So, you know, the set of
strategies is a bit different though in
this game. So, let's be a little So,
what So, So, can you say that a bit more
precisely?
It's the Nash equilibrium where the
action in history is the same as G's
Nash equilibrium. Yeah, so I would say
it's the strategy profile where we
play the Nash equilibrium of G at every
history.
Right? But there's a key point there
that we can't just say it's the Nash
equilibrium of G because the set of
strategies in G are different. So,
namely
uh
maybe I'll say
Maybe I'll give notation. Maybe that
would be nice. So,
unique Nash equilibrium Let's add some
notation. A star.
So, I'm just giving a a name to the
unique Nash equilibrium. This is an
action profile.
Then this has unique Nash equilibrium,
namely
S
of H equals A star
for every history H.
So, now we're sort of formalizing what
you said.
A strategy
in the repeated game has to say how we
play how is you know, a strategy profile
needs to say how every player plays at
every history.
And
we're going to specify that whatever the
history is, we all follow the Nash
equilibrium profile.
Um
maybe if I want to be a little more
precise, maybe I'll say SI equals AI
star for every history H and every
player I.
So, if I'm player I, what do I do?
I have to specify what I do at every
history. What am I going to do? Just
what I'm supposed to do in the Nash
equilibrium of the stage game.
In particular, this strategy is history
independent. How I play does not depend
on how I played in the past.
Or how other people played in the past.
And this means we don't really have any
rewards or punishments.
You know, this result is true if the
unique Nash equilibrium is mixed, but
we'll kind of think for the proof, let's
think of this as being pure to make it a
bit easier, but the result will be true
uh either way. So, let's try to prove
this.
And
let's assume
that A star is pure.
Just to make the proof easier. The
result goes through, but we haven't
really talked about mixed strategies and
we don't really want to get into that.
So, let's just say that this unique Nash
equilibrium is pure.
Uh
Let me be clear. I'm not saying that
it's not enough to just say it's unique
among the pure Nash equilibrium. I'm
saying it's um
there's only one equilibrium
and that equilibrium happens to be pure.
All right. Well, we basically want to
replicate the argument that we used in
the prisoner's dilemma.
Uh so,
let's suppose
that
S star
or S equals
S1 through SN
is a Nash equilibrium is a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
So, we're going to consider some
strategy profile and let's assume it's a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium and we
want to say that if it is a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium, it has to take
this very special form.
Well, what we want to do is you want to
work backwards. So, let's look at our
periods.
0 1 2
And I'll give kind of a a verbal proof.
What do we know
must be true
within period T? How must we all play
in the final period, period T?
Yeah. Uh you just play I basically
Right. And And why Why do we know that
that has to be the case? Because we
talked about how all the histories
independent on the first T games.
So, that
you just have like the
one subgame. You just play by the Nash
equilibrium.
Exactly right. So, once you've gotten to
here
it's always easier to work backwards
because at the end there's less to worry
about. How I play in the last game can't
have any effect in the future cuz
there's no future ahead of me. This is
the last game. So, my only choice today
is
how do I want to influence my flow
payoffs in the game today?
And
if this is supposed to be
if this is a Nash equilibrium of any
every subgame, well, what we know is
that we must have
S of HT
equals AI star
for every
HT in AT.
So, I'm saying whatever history we're at
in this last period, period T
this history starts a subgame.
We have to be playing a Nash equilibrium
within this subgame, but this subgame is
just the same as the stage game because
there's only one We're in the last
period, all we're doing is choosing how
to play the stage game once.
And therefore, we must be playing a Nash
equilibrium, but there's only one Nash
equilibrium, so we must be playing that.
And now we want to move backwards. So,
maybe now I'll go to period
T minus 1. So, formally it's kind of a
proof by induction, but I'm just going
to
try to do it verbally.
So, now what happens in period T minus
1?
Well, in principle
how I behave in period T minus 1 could
be more complicated because I have to
anticipate that the way I play in period
T minus 1 might change the way that we
play in period T. The future is more
complicated now.
But because I know that this is what's
happening in period T, I don't have to
worry about that. Right? What I know is
that if this is how we're playing in
period T
then how we're playing in period T is
independent of how I play in period T
minus 1.
So, now
I just need to maximize my payoff in the
stage game and the only way that can be
the case is if we're playing a Nash
equilibrium the stage game. So, if we
work backwards, we see that
SI of HT - 1
equals AI star
for every history
HT - 1
in AT - 1.
And then we can just keep going back
until we get to period zero, when we'll
see that SI of the empty set must equal
AI star.
>> [clears throat]
>> But notice the ordering really was
crucial. It was crucial that we knew
what we were going to do in the future
in order to figure out our incentives to
play today.
Yes.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, so it's exactly backward
induction, but I want to be careful when
we say fixed.
It's not It's not just that it's fixed
What's crucial is that it's Yeah, it's
independent of the history
that it's The crucial thing is that what
we do in period T does not depend on HT.
If it did depend on HT,
then it would have to then things would
be more complicated because what I do
today
could affect how we end up playing
tomorrow because what I do today, I
guess the key the key issue and maybe
I'll
Yeah, we'll start start over here.
So, maybe let's go kind of the
What's the key issue in
in repeated games?
It's that
my action AIT
has two effects.
It affects my flow payoff.
Namely, UI
So, if this is how my opponents are
playing in period T,
the action that I choose directly
affects my flow payoff.
But it also affects future play.
Why?
Well,
AIT
changes
the history
H
S
for all S greater than or equal to T.
Because
any subsequent history specifies exactly
what happens so far.
So, if I behave differently in period
nine,
then the history that the players
observe in period 10 is going to depend
on what I did in period nine.
And in particular, that might therefore
change actions.
And this is This is sort of the
fundamental trade-off that we always
face in repeated games. I have to
compare how my action today
affects my flow payoffs today and also
how it affects what happens in future
play of the game.
If we go over here, let's look at what
happened in period T - 1.
The first effect was still true, or the
second this this effect is still true.
It's still true that at period T - 1, my
action changes the history tomorrow.
But this is what broke down.
If the way that we play tomorrow is
independent of the history, then the
fact that my action changes the history
doesn't mean that the actions are going
to be different because the actions
tomorrow are independent of the history.
Right?
Um
namely, this
this property.
So, sure, if I change my action at T -
1, I might change HT. I'm going to
change the history that everyone sees
tomorrow.
But if the way we play is A star, no
matter what that history is, then the
fact that I change that history doesn't
matter at all.
And therefore, I could ignore the effect
of my action
on future play and only focus on the
effect of my action on my flow payoff,
but that means we're effectively just
playing the stage game, and we already
know that has a Nash equilibrium.
Again, we could do it all the algebra I
and and you can look in the notes for
the kind of more formal algebraic
argument, but I just find it easier just
to kind of think through it verbally uh
than the algebra. Yes, question. Kind of
the main point is that like
if future actions were not dependent on
the history, then my current action
action today
Exactly, and we'll do an example of that
exactly next, yeah.
Um
I guess technically what I've shown
here, I should be careful. I've shown
that if something's a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium, we must play the stage
game Nash every period. I technically
also have to check that playing the
subgame playing the Nash every period is
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium, but
uh that's also not too hard to show. So,
I'll just say
and this is maybe a good exercise,
use the one-shot deviation principle
to show that this
is a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
Right? I showed that the only possible
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium is
this, but of course, it could be that
there's no subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium. So, you should actually
check that this is a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium, and it's exactly the
same reasoning, right? I just have to
check that there's no profitable
one-shot deviation, and we go through
basically the same reasoning, but uh
maybe I'll leave that as an exercise.
All right, so I don't want to give the
impression that repetition can't have
any effect,
and it turns out that this result, it is
very very special that we have a unique
Nash equilibrium in the stage game. And
if we have multiple Nash equilibria,
this result is no longer true. So, uh
let's
let's go through that.
So, let's go through maybe the oldest
game that's
been formalized
is we're going to study the stag hunt.
So, I think Rousseau talked about this
in maybe the 1600s.
And the story is you have two hunters.
They can either hunt hare, which is
easy, you do it by yourself, or they can
hunt a big stag, and they have to do
that together.
So, they can choose Each of them
chooses, do we try to
kind of cooperate and hunt hat stag
together, or do we just hunt for hare on
our own?
And if we both hunt for stag, then we
both succeed. We get the stag, and
therefore we each get a payoff of two.
Payoff is going to be two, two.
Now, hare is not as good as uh stag,
just a a rabbit. If we both hunt for
rabbits on our own, we each get one.
We each get a rabbit, and but a rabbit
is worse than a stag. So, we each just
get one, one.
But then, the tricky thing is what
happens here.
What if I hunt for hare
as player one and player two hunts for
stag?
Well, I'll still get one
because I can hunt for hare by myself,
but now I've kind of screwed over the
other person
because they're hunting for stag by
themselves now. They're not going to be
able to successfully get a stag, and
they're going to get a payoff of zero.
So, the idea is, do we pursue the small
prey that we can achieve by ourselves,
or the big prey that requires
cooperation? If you seek out the big
prey by yourself, you get nothing
uh and and you fail.
So, this is going to have multiple
equilibria.
Uh let's just go through it. If my
opponent is hunting for stag, then I
also want to hunt for stag because if I
know they're hunting for stag, then I
can join them and we'll get stag, and
that's great.
But if my opponent is hunting for hare,
I also want to hunt for hare because if
I hunt stag by myself, I get nothing.
And now we can do the symmetric thing.
And you know, Rousseau didn't really
write it out quite this way, but he was
trying to make the point that the nature
of society uh can have a big impact. We
can be a society of stag hunters who do
really well because we all trust each
other, or we can be a society of hare
hunters who don't do as well, and these
are both consistent and and stable uh
courses of action. Of course, he didn't
have the notion of Nash equilibrium, but
but he talks about this in his uh in his
book in the 1600s.
But for our purposes, the key point is
that this has two Nash equilibria.
Namely, SS
and HH.
So, now let's consider the
uh repeated version of this.
Um
maybe let's look at stag hunt
with T equals one. So, we're just going
to play stag hunt twice.
And there's actually going to be a lot
of subgame perfect Nash equilibria.
Uh let's look for a few.
Um
Let's first look for
subgame perfect Nash equilibria
where I might say there's no rewards and
punishments.
What do I mean by that? I mean, let's
look for SPNE
where
the The we play in T equals one doesn't
depend on how we played in t equals
zero.
Our play is history independent. Again,
if there's no contingency, if the way we
play tomorrow doesn't affect how it
doesn't depend on how we play today,
then the way we play today doesn't have
any effect on tomorrow, and we could
just focus on the stage games.
So,
any guesses for some kind of simple SPNE
that have this property? Maybe I'll
write
period zero
and period one. There's actually a a
number of choices here. Any any guesses
for some some really simple SPNE where
there's no contingency? We just kind of
ignore the past.
Well, one thing we could do is we could
just always hunt stag.
We know that's a Nash equilibrium of the
stage game.
So, maybe I'll be a little informal and
I'll just write we could do SS SS.
So, formally what I mean is in period
zero, we each hunt stag, and in period
one, we each hunt stag regardless of the
history in period zero. So, remember if
I really formally wrote out the strategy
here, I'm actually saying SS at four
different contingencies.
Right? Um
>> [snorts]
>> Great.
So, that's one thing we could do.
Is this an a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium? Well, yes, because
in period one, we're each playing a Nash
equilibrium. That's great.
In period zero, how I play today has no
effect on what happens in period one, so
all we need to check is that I'm playing
a a Nash equilibrium today, and indeed
that works out. So, here's one.
Any other examples of SPNE that don't
have any rewards or punishments? They
don't have any contingencies.
Yeah.
We could always hunt hare, right?
So, again, in each of these subgames,
it's obviously a Nash equilibrium. We
just have to check that it's a Nash
equilibrium of this main subgame. But
because the way we play tomorrow doesn't
depend on the way we play today, it's
it's a Nash equilibrium, we're good. I'd
argue there's actually even some more.
Any
Any other things we could do?
Yeah. If you hunt stag in the first
period, both of you, and then hunt hare
in the next one. Exactly.
Great.
So, you might think, wait, oh, this has
punishments because we're playing
differently tomorrow. But no,
punishments are about
making what we do tomorrow contingent on
what we do today. So, what I'm saying,
or what our friend here is saying, is we
both hunt stag today.
Tomorrow we hunt hare, but we hunt hare
whatever happened today.
If we both hunted hare today, we hunt
hare tomorrow. If we both hunted stag
today, we hunt hare tomorrow. If it was
SH or HS, we still do hare tomorrow. So,
again, there's no contingency, and we
can go through it. Clearly a Nash
equilibrium of this subgame,
and then clearly a Nash equilibrium here
because all I care about is my flow
payoffs, and SS is a Nash equilibrium of
the stage game.
And then as you pointed out, we have
one final one where we do HH
and SS.
And maybe if I want to be more precise,
what I mean
I mean at every
H1. Right? That's when I write this
down, I'm really specifying four things.
I'm saying at every history H1, there's
four of them, SS, HH,
HS, SH,
this is what happens.
So, here we have four subgame perfect
Nash equilibria that involve no rewards
or punishments, and they're pretty easy
to analyze.
But now we want to see if we can
do a little more.
Any questions on on this before we
Okay.
So, now we all go to this board.
So, what's the question?
Can we find
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
in which we don't play a stage game Nash
in period zero?
So,
>> [clears throat]
>> in each of these subgame perfect Nash
equilibria that we looked at, we played
a Nash equilibrium of the stage game in
period zero. I'm asking, can we find a
different subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium
in which
we do not play
a Nash equilibrium of the stage game?
So, let's just try to think through
this.
Well, we might say, wait, we that's
impossible. We can apply our theorem,
but why can't we apply our theorem here?
Our theorem told us there's only one
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium. We
already found multiple, so something's
going on. So, why doesn't the theorem
apply to this setting? Yeah.
Uh cuz it doesn't have unique
Exactly
right. Our theorem was only applied to
games where the or stage games with
unique Nash
and hurts you or benefits them today,
tomorrow you might punish them by
behaving differently, right? And that's
a way of deterring them from engaging in
this action. They may be some I maybe
this is a a negative view of human
affairs, I don't know, but this I think
does happen
certainly between firms
colluding, this happens.
All right, so this is all kind of
abstract. Now, what's tricky is
we need to punish the deviation
tomorrow,
but we know that tomorrow is the last
period.
And we know that in the last period of a
game,
we have to be playing a Nash equilibrium
of the stage game.
Because this is this is kind of a a key
property. In the last period, there's no
future, so you must be playing a stage
game Nash. So, we need to punish you
tomorrow, but we can only punish you by
playing a Nash equilibrium.
So, this seems a little tricky, but the
key is that we have multiple Nash
equilibria.
So, we can punish you tomorrow
how? By playing a different Nash
equilibrium.
And this really gets to the core of the
difference between our theorem and our
game here.
In the last period, we have to play a
Nash equilibrium.
If there's only one Nash equilibrium,
then we know how we have to play in the
last period, and there's no scope for
punishments or rewards.
If our game has multiple Nash equilibria
like the stage stag hunt, now we still
have to play a Nash equilibrium in the
last period, but which Nash equilibrium
we play can depend on our past behavior.
So, there might be a good Nash
equilibrium that can serve as a reward,
and a bad Nash equilibrium that can
serve as a punishment. So, let's let's
try to go through that.
So, the idea
is we want a good Nash equilibrium
as a reward.
Things could be a bit more complicated.
A Nash equilibrium could be good for
some people and bad for others, but
let's start with this really simple
case.
And a bad Nash equilibrium as a
punishment.
So in this stag hunt game, what is going
to be the reward and what is going to be
the the punishment?
Well, we can look, right? SS is the good
equilibrium and HH is the bad
equilibrium. So what we want is we want
SS
to serve as a reward for good behavior
and we want HH to serve as a punishment
for bad behavior.
So what we say is
if you don't do what you're supposed to
today, then tomorrow we're both going to
hunt hare. That's bad for you. If you do
do what you're supposed to do, then
we're going to hunt stag tomorrow and
that's better for you.
Uh so let's
see if this works out.
So let's try to let's be a bit more
specific.
I want to find an SPNE in which in
period zero we play something that's not
a stage game Nash. Let's be more
specific and let's look for an SPNE
where in period zero we play
Well, we don't want to play a Nash. So
that means we're playing one of these
and it's kind of symmetric. It doesn't
really matter which one we choose, but
let's choose this one. So let's play HS.
So let's try to
fill in our
table. I think this is kind of a good
way to go about it. Um so let me kind of
remember I think the hardest thing about
sometimes finding equilibria is figuring
out what kind of object they are, like
how many positions, how many things you
have to fill in. So let's kind of make a
blank table and then we'll gradually
fill it in and try to construct our
subgame perfect So what is our table
going to look like? Well, we have um
our histories.
We have the empty history
and then we have four histories after
that. We have SS
SH
HS and HH.
So to be clear, these are period zero
histories.
And these are period one histories.
And then for each history we have to
specify
how player one plays and how player two
plays, right? So let's say let's put
player one here and player two here and
maybe let's put in kind of a a spot.
So just to be clear, when I'm asking to
solve for an SPNE, I'm asking to specify
10 things.
Five things for player one and five
things for player two.
Because player one has five information
sets and player two has five information
sets and we're looking for a strategy
profile.
So the goal is to fill this in in such a
way that we get a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium in which this is what
happens in period zero. So we first have
a very easy thing to fill in. We want
this to happen in period zero. So we're
going to fill in
HS, right?
And now HS is just written this way, so
it's player one followed by player two.
Okay.
So now we need to fill in what happens
in period one to try to make this
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
So the first observation
is that whatever we do in period one at
every history, it must be a Nash
equilibrium.
Because we know in the last period the
the the subgame is just the same as the
stage game cuz there's nothing else that
comes in the future. So what we're
choosing basically is we need to It's
almost like a kind of a word search. We
have
HH and SS. These are our Nash
equilibria.
And we need to choose where to put HH
and where to put SS.
So we could be really mechanical about
it, but uh
for I mean then we have uh
16 different choices, so that's going to
take us a while. So let's be a little
thoughtful, right? We could put either
SS here or HH here, either SS here or HH
here and so on. Uh but that's kind of a
a silly way to do it, so let's let's try
to think more. Um any guesses about
where we should put
HH and where we should put SS?
Maybe any thoughts about one
one position?
Mhm?
Uh
SS goes under SS. I'm not so sure. So
let's understand, right? We want a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
where we play HS in the first period,
right? So you might be thinking we want
SS, but we're trying to get people to
play HS in the first period.
So
you said put SS under SS?
So if we put SS under SS, that would
make it appealing to play SS today,
right?
Uh so let's think
So say again?
Right. Uh exactly. So let's let's
actually start Let's start I think this
is the kind of easy Let's start here,
okay?
We're trying to encourage people to play
HS today, right? So we want to reward
them if they do play HS today with a
good equilibrium. So let's reward them
by playing SS tomorrow.
Now I want to be clear, when we're
computing repeated game equilibria, it's
very tempting and it's it's very
convenient to think about choosing
an action profile rather than just an
action. So I'm saying we're going to
play SS tomorrow.
But we have to really understand it's
always the case that a single player is
choosing how they're playing. We're
never jointly choosing what to do. It's
just as the analyst when I'm analyzing
it, it's convenient to think about where
we put SS, but
each player is making a decision for
themselves. I just want to keep that
clear.
Okay. So
what we've set up so far is we've made
it so that if we play HS, which is how
we want people to play, we want this to
be a Nash equilibrium, we're going to be
rewarded tomorrow by playing SS.
We also need to think about punishments.
Let's try to punish the players if
anyone unilaterally deviates.
So if player one unilaterally deviates,
what happens?
Player one is supposed to play H. If
they deviate, they play S and therefore
the history is SS.
So because SS is a history that could
result from a unilateral deviation by
player one, in order to punish that, we
want to put HH here.
Conversely, if player two deviates
from S to H, then the history is going
to be HH. So we also want to punish HH
with HH.
What about
this remaining history?
Uh should we put HH here or
SS here?
Or does it matter?
Turns out this it won't matter at all.
Why? Well,
remember Nash equilibrium and subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium is all about
unilateral deviations.
So if we're interested in the incentives
for people to unilateral unilaterally
deviate, we have to say what happens if
player one unilaterally deviates to S
or player two unilaterally deviates to
H.
But there's no unilateral deviation from
HS that will result in SH.
Right? That would mean that player one
had deviated from H to S
and player two had deviated from S to H.
But if they both deviate, well that's
not a unilateral deviation. So it turns
out whether this is an equilibrium will
not actually depend on what happens
here. So we could either do HH or SS.
Let's do HH, but uh SS would also work.
It can't be SH though. It's either HH or
SS. So maybe I should have big
parentheses
to make that clear.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, so now let's try to
check whether this is indeed a
Nash equilibrium, a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
Now there's a lot to check.
We have to check that this forms a Nash
equilibrium
in every subgame.
So we have to check all five subgames.
But the the one shot deviation principle
is going to help us, right? Technically
we have to check that in every subgame
there's no profitable deviation.
But the one shot deviation principle
says we just have to check that there's
no profitable one shot deviation. So
check in all five subgames
there is no
profitable
one shot deviation.
>> So the period one subgames are pretty
easy, but let's just do one of them to
check as an example.
So in period one we have four subgames.
Let's look at the subgame following HH.
Just uh
uh
make sure we understand.
So let's consider player one.
Player one is supposed to play H.
At history HH, player one is supposed to
play H. So let's compare two things.
What happens if player one plays H
and what happens if player one plays S?
So let's understand what I'm doing here.
I'm contemplating
a one-shot deviation by player one
at history HH. I'm saying suppose we're
at history HH and player one
unilaterally deviates
instead of playing H they play S and we
want to compare the payoffs, okay?
So what if player one
plays H as he's supposed to do?
What is player one's average payoff in
the entire game going to be?
Well, we're at the HH history.
So we the way we compute payoffs is we
already assume that HH was played in the
first period. So that gives player one a
payoff of one.
And then if I play H again, I also get
one because my opponent is also playing
H.
So we're going to get a payoff of 1 + 1
over 2
which equals one.
What if I unilaterally deviate to S?
What is my payoff going to be?
Well, if I unilaterally deviate to S
and maybe let's write let me be very
clear about what it happens here.
So if at history HH
I do what I'm supposed to and I play H
and my opponent also plays H, then this
is what our payoff is going to be. The
the path of play is HH in period zero,
HH in period one, and my payoff is is is
an average of one.
If I unilaterally deviate to S
then after history HH, I unilaterally
deviate to S, but my opponent stays at
H.
Which means my payoff is now 1 + 0 over
which equals 1/2.
And indeed deviating is not profitable.
So So what I've checked is there's no
one-shot profitable deviation for player
one
at HH. I guess we do that eight times
because there's four histories and two
players, so it's a bit of a mess, but
it's not too hard to check that that's
going to work out.
So now let's go to period zero. This is
where I think the action is.
So let's look at period zero.
And we're at So the history is just
nothing. Nothing has happened.
And let's look at
player one
and player two.
And in period zero, player one is
supposed to play H.
But they could also play S.
And player two is supposed to play
uh S.
But they could also play H.
So to check that neither player has a
profitable one-shot deviation, I need to
say what if player one
instead of playing H as they're supposed
to
one-shot deviates to playing S at this
history
and then follows the strategy from there
on out.
And ask the same about player two and
check that these deviations are not
going to be profitable. Okay?
So I think that the first thing before
we can compute payoffs is figure out
what happens.
So if player one
does what they're supposed to and plays
H today
then what's going to happen is we're
going to get HS today
followed by
SS tomorrow.
Right? This is what's supposed to
happen.
And the same is true down here. If
player two does what they're supposed to
we get HS followed by SS.
But what happens if player one
unilaterally deviates to SS?
Then
we get SS today.
But then what happens tomorrow?
Yeah?
HH, exactly.
And let's ask the same with player two.
If they deviate from S to H
then we're going to get
HH today.
And then what happens tomorrow?
Yeah?
HH, right?
So now we can exactly see what we're
discussing.
If player one unilaterally deviates,
they get a benefit today
because SS is better than HS, but then
they get punished tomorrow because they
get HH tomorrow rather than SS.
And the same thing goes down here.
And instead of adding it all up, I think
it's easier to see
what is the gain from the deviation in
going from HS to SS?
Well, if they did
Oh, maybe let's just write it all out.
Player one's payoff from HS is going to
be one
two
one.
And here player two's payoff is one
one
zero two.
So if we add it all up, we're going to
get an average of three halves
three halves
one
one.
So I've just gone through and computed
the flow payoff that player one gets in
each situation and then I've taken the
average. And then I've computed the flow
payoff player two gets in each situation
and then I've computed the average.
And what we indeed see is that if player
one unilaterally deviates, well actually
their payoff is going to be exactly
unchanged, so it's not profitable.
If player two unilaterally deviates,
their payoff is exactly unchanged, so
it's not profitable and therefore we see
that these deviations are not profitable
and we're we're done here.
And we can exactly see the effect. If
player one says, "Wait a second, you're
asking me to
to hunt for hare when my opponent's
hunting for stag? I'd much rather hunt
for stag and get a higher payoff."
Indeed your flow payoff would jump up by
one. It would jump from one to two if
you deviated. The problem is that
tomorrow you're going to be punished
with HH which reduces your payoff by
one.
So the punishment you experience
tomorrow is just large enough to offset
the gain you experienced today and
therefore the deviation is not
profitable. And the same happens for
player two.
Okay, let me uh stop there and I'll see
everyone on Thursday.